prepare for another tough road test and
this time it's going to be cleveland
brian yeah the browns will be a really
good measuring stick for the silver and
black and the franchise quarterback
john treach has more being a quarterback
isn't about how you play when everything
goes as planned it's about how you make
magic amid the madness
a positive play when everything else
falls apart john gruden says he sees his
guy
improving with improv clearly improved
i think each of the last couple years i
think
the supporting cast has also improved
but
his accuracy down the field has been
impressive his mobility in the pocket
has been good been really accurate and i
see improvement in a lot of areas yes
and he has extended some plays
big first down the other day scramble
for a touchdown pass to winton against
buffalo
some memorable plays with his feet this
year and we're excited about that
carr is completing an incredible 72
percent of his passes this year and in
2020 he's not dinking and dunking
derrick
number four is taking shots downfield
that's a part of
what coach wants to do you know and so
when they're healthy and we're rolling
and
you know it there's a rhythm to it too
you know the play calling the game
planning you know who you have every
week you know
then you start oh that looks good or
that now we can do this or now we can do
that off of that you know all that kind
of stuff
now it's just becoming who we are
reporting from las vegas
john